HOUSING AND COMMUNITY ELEMENT
COMMITTEE MEETING OF FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER THE TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF OUR STAFF WE'VE MADE. A
RETURN TO THE CAPITOL TO HEAR
BILLS POSSIBLE DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN
THIS HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL. WE CAN ONLY HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING
IN PERSON. WE REQUIRE THE MAST
BE WARNING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BE MAINTAINED. IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
TO YOU IT'S THE CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE IN THE HOUSE THAT
MEMBERS ARE PROPERLY ATTIRED.
AND FOR THIS HEARING WEARING A
MASK IS ALSO REQUIREMENTS OF
BEING PROPERLY ATTIRED. WE'VE
THREE BILLS IN ARGENTA TODAY
EACH BUILDING UP TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. EACH MAIN WITNESS
WILL GET TWO MINUTES EACH. FOR
ALL OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
RECALLING A REGISTER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL. WE ASK
THAT YOU ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. IF YOU SAY MORE
THE OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF.
IF YOU CANNOT GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THIS WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE BILL. YOU CAN
ALSO SUBMIT AN EMAIL TO
COMMITTEE STAFF. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A COUPLE OF OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. IN THE
ROOM- IF ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC
WISHES TO TESTIFY RAISE YOUR
HAND I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE AND PLEASE
EXIT THE HER ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING. WE ALSO HAVE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION WHICH
IS LOCATED ON THE NORTH SIDE OF
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS I SIDE OF
THE BUILDING. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON SCREEN SO THAT
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE LIVE
TESTIMONY. WE'RE ALSO USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY TO BUILD THE CALLING
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THIS
NUMBER IS ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND YOUR TELEVISION
SCREEN. IF YOU CALL IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS THE BILL
AUTHOR IS BEGINNING A
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING AND PLEASE ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE. AND BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS YOUR MAN ON A LIFELINE
AND YOU HAVE TO MEET YOURSELF
AND YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK
IF YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
EIGHT FIVE AND MY STAFF CAN
ASSIST YOU. AND ALSO AGAIN NOTE
THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. SO WITH
THAT. AT THIS MOMENT WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS PRESENT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO I'M GONNA
CALL FOR ALL MEMBERS TO JOIN
US. IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- AND WITH THAT WE
HAVE OUR FIRST BILL AUTHORED
HERE FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
SEVEN MISTER GRAYSON MISTER
GRAYSON WELCOME. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND GOOD MORNING
TO YOU AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBER.
HI I AM PLEASED THAT TO PRESENT
AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN. IT'S SIMPLE
RESULTS THREE TECHNICAL ISSUES
AND THESE ISSUES- HAVE RISEN
WITH RESPECT TO STATE LAW
GOVERNING LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. SO AB FOUR
FOUR SEVEN RESOLVES THESE THREE
TECHNICAL ISSUES BY ADDING THE
MISSING PROGRAMS FROM THE
PRESERVATION NOTICE LAW INTO
THAT LIHTC STATUTES EXCLUDING A
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. OR OTHER
REGULATORY AGREEMENT RECORDED
IN CONNECTION WITH AN ARM OR
ACQUISITION FINANCING FROM
CONSIDERATION WINDY CAC
DETERMINES A PROPERTIES. AT
RISK STATUS AND THE DEFINING
NEW CONSTRUCTION TO INCLUDE
ADAPTIVE RE USE THE STREET
TECHNICAL CHANGES WILL
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AND IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BUILD THIS MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU WANT TO GO NOW TO
YOUR MAIN WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
MARC DIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
AND THESE MODEST CHANGES WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP US PRESERVE
THE AFFORDABILITY OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOMES ARE AT RISK OF
CONVERTING TO MARKET RIGHT SO
WE APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I THERE
IS NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION SO
LET'S NOW GO. LET'S SEE IF
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO STATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL OR
OPPOSITION. NOT SEEN ANYONE
HERE IN THIS ROOM LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE REMOTE.
TESTIMONY STATION SEEN NONE.
LET'S GO TO THE OPERATOR- TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE. INDIVIDUALS
THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. I AND IF YOU ARE
A TESTIFYING IF YOU COULD
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE.
DAVID CHIU SAN FRANCISCO. I OR
SUPPORT. TO THE OPERATOR. THANK
YOU EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN THE
COMMANDERS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT AND LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION. ON THE
TELEPHONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE FIRST ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THANK
YOU WE HAVE DONE LINES IN Q.
RIGHT LET'S BRING BACK TO
COMMIT ANY COMMENTS. I WANTED
JUST TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVE THIS FORWARD AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS- WHO WHO'S VERY FIRST
BILL HERE I THAT I INTRODUCED
SEVEN YEARS AGO WAS TO. EXPAND
OUR LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT- REALLY PLEASED TO HELP
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
TO USE THESE FUNDS FOR A WIDER
RANGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS- WE KNOW AND I JUST
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LONGSTANDING. WORK ON HOUSING-
HE KNOWS AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE IS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION IN THIS BILL IS GOING
TO HELP US BETTER LEVERAGE.
THIS PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD AND
WITH THAT ANY FINAL COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL OKAY
WELL WE DO NOT HAVE QUORUM YET
BUT WHEN WE DO I WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
THANK YOU. FOR IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FILE ITEM TO HIS
ACTION MINES I'M GONNA ASK OUR
VICE CHAIR IF HE WILL TAKE THE
GAVEL. AND I DIDN'T SEE CENTER
ARE. OF COURSE. SENATOR WELCOME.
I WOULD BE HAPPY. TO FILE ITEM
THREE SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
SENATOR PORTANTINO GOOD TO SEE
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- EIGHTY ONE
HAS ONLY BEEN SIXTY YEARS IN
THE MAKING. AND I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE IT HERE- BEFORE YOU- IT
MAKES CHANGES IN THE
DISPOSITION OF THE SEVEN ARE
TEN HOMES PROCESS WHICH ARE
OWNED BY CALTRANS IT'S- POLICE
HAVE SOLVED A LOT OF PROBLEMS
IT GIVES THE EXISTING TENANTS.
OF MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN IN
THERE FOR DECADES- MORE RIGHTS
TO PURCHASE THE HOMES THAT
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING IN. IT
GIVES THE CITY OF THOUGHT SOUTH
PASADENA THE ABILITY TO
pACQUISITION PRICE IT PRESERVES
HISTORIC HOMES BUT ALSO MOST
IMPORTANTLY AS A THREE TO ONE
MULTIPLIER TO FOR EVERY HOME
THEY GET SOLD AT MARKET RATE-
THE STORE COMES THE CITY WOULD
HAVE TO PROVIDE THREE
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND SO. THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT IN
THE CITY IN A CORRIDOR THAT.
THE NEEDS OF PORTABLE HOUSING
IT ALSO GETS CALTRANS OUT OF
THE HOUSING BUSINESS- WHICH WE
WANT TO DO FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES AND I HAVE TO GIVE A
BIG SHOUT OUT TO MY STAFF TO
CALTRANS STATE CD THE CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TOGETHER.
WE'VE GOTTEN INPUT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- WE'VE REALLY
WORKED HARD TO GET THE BILL IN
THE SHAPE IT'S IN AND OUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS- ONE
WE NOW GO TO YOUR MAIN WITNESS
ON THE TELEPHONE ANDERSTON THE
MAYOR. OF SOUTH PASADENA. IS ON
TO THE OPERATOR. YES HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. WALK
IN THERE EXCELLENT MY NAME IS
DIANA MAHMUD I'M PRESENTLY THE
MAYOR AND THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA. AND WE ARE SO EXCITED
TO BE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
HAVING THIS BILL. FINALLY BE
ENACTED BECAUSE AS- SENATOR.
SAID WE HAVE LONG HELD CALTRANS
HOMES IN OUR PROPERTY THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN WELL MAINTAINED
MANY ARE IN THE STATE OF
EXTREME DISREPAIR. AND IF
CALTRANS KNEW THAT IT LIKELY
WOULD NOT BE- CONSTRUCTING THE
FREE WAY. IT DID NOT. HAVE RENT
THE HOMES AND SO MANY OF THE
HOMES ARE VACANT. AND AFFECTS
THEY REALLY HAVE BEEN THE
SOURCE OF EXTREME CONCERN WITH
THE POTENTIAL. FOR POLITE AND
BREAK INS- CALTRANS FACES
VARIOUS SAFETY IN THE SENATE
CONSEQUENCES THAT THE
NEGLECTED. PROPERTIES AND WE
ARE STILL EXCITED NOW FINALLY.
TO ACHIEVE WHAT I BELIEVE IS A
WIN WIN FOR BOTH THE STATE AND
FOR. MY RESIDENTS AND I MIGHT
POINT OUT THAT AND MY CITY HAS
FORGONE. PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
WERE VERY SMALL CITY. THREE AND
A HALF SQUARE MILES WE HAVE NO
BIG BOX- THE MAJORITY OF OUR
REVENUE COMES FROM- FROM
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE OVER
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND RESIDENTS
HALF OF MY- RESIDENTS ARE
HOMEOWNERS- HALF OF THEM ARE
RANCHERS. HALF OF THEM LIVE IN
MULTI FAMILY UNITS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK REALLY SET
SOUTH PASADENA PART. IS THE
FACT THAT WE WERE ESTABLISHED
IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF HITORIC
HOMES. THE AMENDMENT TO THIS
BILL THAT NAPLES IS TO SELL
THOSE HISTORIC HOMES AT MARKET
VALUE AND THEN USE THE
PROCEEDS. TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON A THREE TO ONE BASIS
IS KEY BECAUSE- WE HAVE ONE OF
THE BEST SCHOOL. DISTRICTS IN
THE REGION IF NOT THE STATE AND
WITH SO MANY. IT I IT IS A
PERSONAL- OBJECTIVES STRONG
OBJECTIVE OF MINE TO BE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR CITY
AND SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
PARTICULARLY WITH ITS MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS- AND ALSO.
ALLOWING THE CITY TO REQUIRE
THE PROPERTIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
HELD BY CALTRANS FOR DECADES
HAVE NOT BEEN WELL MAINTAINED
WE BELIEVE THERE'S GOING TO BE
AN AWFUL LOT OF- HEAT. AND
REPAIR TO THE HOMES BEFORE THEY
CAN BE MADE IN GOOD CONDITION
FOR OUR AFFORDABLE. CANNONS AND
WE'RE EXCITED TO DO THAT WE
CERTAINLY URGE YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MAYOR- BEFORE WE PROCEED CENTER
I THINK YOU ATTRACTED OVER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ACTUALLY
PHYSICALLY. JOIN US SO I'D LIKE
TO TAKE THE ROLE AT THIS POINT
TO ESTABLISH KERR. TWENTY TWO
YEAR TO YEAR THEY ARE JOKES.
HERE ARE IN HERE RIGHT.
GABRIELLE GABRIEL HERE KALRA.
HOLLERITH HERE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN QUICKSILVER THANKS
SILVA HERE WICKS WICKS HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OPPOSITION WITNESS SO LET US
GO TO SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THERE IS
ONE HERE IN THIS HEARING ROOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE GOING
TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. THERE ARE NO MEMBERS
THERE- OPERATOR LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND
AGAIN IF YOU COULD PLEASE AYE
SIX YOU JUST LOST HER NAME HE
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES INTO IT THIS
TIME GREAT LET'S NOW GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE
OPPOSE IN THE BILL HERE AND
THIS HEARING ROOM OR AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
OPERATOR IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE TO WISH TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ALLOW THEM TO STATE THAT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- TO THE AUTHOR JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN. TOILING
MIGHTILY TO GET THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE SAME PAGE-
AND HER COLLEAGUES WERE HERE IN
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE IT WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED ON THE
FLOOR- AFTER WE HEARD THIS
BILL. EARLIER THIS YEAR- TO
ADDRESS THE SITUATION OF
HISTORIC SURPLUS PROPERTIES ON
THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAY- I KNOW
THIS IS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE FOR THE AUTHOR AS WELL AS
OTHERS AND JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
CREATIVE SOLUTION. THAT SHOULD
HOPEFULLY LEAD TO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE AREA-
WITH THAT ANY COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION MOVED AND THERE'S A
SECOND TO IT. AND WESTERN IN
THE COMMENTS BACK TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU FOR THE CARE
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF- IT HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AND I
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMITTEES-
EFFORT TO HELP US GET IT HERE
AS WELL AND EVERYONE THAT'S
WORKED SO. COOPER TO CLEAN
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION
IS TO PASS A TWO. BY TWO I SAY
ARE DON'T KNOW. YARD AND NO
GABRIELLE. GABRIEL I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
KIRK SILVA. KIRK SILVA I. WICKS
WEEKS NINE. YOUR PASSES THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE OR BILL PRESENTATION
AND IT'S MINE FILE IN TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN I'M GONNA
HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR OF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS AB THREE EIGHT
SIXTEEN AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SO COLLEAGUES A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT WE HEARD AB
EIGHT SIXTEEN. EARLIER IN THE
YEAR BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
DEADLINES- BUT MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS FROM THAT BILL WERE
ADOPTED AND BUDGET TRAILER AND
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
BUDGET TRAILER- THIS WE
INCLUDED SOME ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS THAT YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY- TO ESSENTIALLY CONTINUE
THE ABILITY OF OUR STATE'S
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUTED ALL MEANT TO
PRIORITIZE NATIONAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND MONIES FOR
PROPERTIES THAT SERVE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHERE SERVICES ARE
PAID FOR THROUGH MEDICAL
BENEFITS IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
IS. WE KNOW THAT FOR SO MANY
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS BEING CURSED
SIGNIFICANT THAT
DISPROPORTIONATE MEDICAL COSTS
ENERGY POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WHO EXPERIENCE A COMBINATION OF
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE SITUATIONS
AS WELL AS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
THAT IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS CARE WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS OFTEN CREATES A
INSIST AND INSTITUTIONAL
CIRCUIT. WHERE FOLKS ARE
CYCLING FROM THE STREETS TO
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
INPATIENT ADMISSIONS
INCARCERATIONS NURSING HOME
STAYS WHICH IS VERY EXPENSIVE
AND WE ARE CONTINUING- THE
FUNDING FOR THIS BILL- TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT IF WE ARE
PROVIDING SUPPORT HOUSING
OPTIONS WE WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
COSTS. TO THE TUNE OF TENS OF
BILLIONS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER INDIVIDUAL ABOUT
THE COST OF HOUSING AND
SERVICES THE STATE HAS
HISTORICALLY RECEIVED ABOUT
THIRTY TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS FUNDING EVERY YEAR JUST
WANNA CONTEXTUALIZE. ARE THAT
AT THIS MOMENT CONGRESS IS
CONSIDERING ALLOCATING OVER
THREE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
TO CALIFORNIA FOR THIS FUN THIS
YEAR THIS BILL WOULD ONLY
REQUIRE FUNDS TO GO TO PROJECTS
FOR PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO THE EXTENT THAT
QUALIFYING PROJECTS APPLY. AND
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR MAIN WITNESS. SO WE HAVE
ONE MAIN WITNESS THAT I'LL BE
SHARING REPORTER SHARON ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE WITH US. YES I AM
NOW YOU NEED MORE DENTURE AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- THE SHERIN REPORT FROM
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST
FUNDS PAY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MOSTLY FOR
PEOPLE WITH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
STATED AB EIGHT ONE SIX
PRIORITIZE CALIFORNIA'S
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUNDS.
TO HOW CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEESE THAT THEIR STATE
HAS AN INTEREST IN PRIORITIZING
THIS POPULATION. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- ALSO
DIED TWENTY FIVE- TO THIRTY
YEARS YOUNGER THAN THEIR HOUSE
COUNTERPARTS- AS WE EXPECT
INCREASES IN THE NATIONAL
HOUSING TRUST FUND. AB EIGHT
ONE SIX PROVIDES MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE MORE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND TO SERVE
OUR POPULATION OUR STATE HAVE
LONG NEGLECTED. THOSE ON FIXED
INCOMES OR RECEIVING LOW WAGES
AND SO CANNOT ACCESS OR SUSTAIN
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY. EVEN
THOUGH THIS POPULATION MAKES UP
ABOUT 60% OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OUR
CAPITAL PROGRAMS TYPICALLY DO
NOT SEARCH THEM. AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN STILL ABOUT THE H. CITY
TO FUND OTHER PROJECTS WITH
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
IT'S SIMPLY PRIORITIZES THESE
FUNDS FOR ONE OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST PRIORITIES. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU FIRST
LEADERSHIP AND SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS. IMPORTANT
BATTLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
FOR HAND- WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
REGISTERED AT THIS TIME FOR
TESTIMONY SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
ADDITIONAL. TESTIMONY BY- AND
THE OTHERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE- REMEMBER
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND
THEN AND THEN ALSO YOUR THAT
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WHEN WE CALL FOR OPPOSITION
WITH. SO AT THIS TIME WILL LOOK
IN THE ROOM THERE DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE ANYTHING YEAH
THERE IS ONE WITNESS IN THE
ROOM GO AHEAD SIR. COACH MIKE.
MARCH DIVERSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR STIVERS
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM. THERE BEING NONE WILL
CHECK THE REMOTE THERE ANY OF
NOBODY IN THE REMOTE. NOT
APPEAR TO BE ANY. SO HIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR CAN WE- HAVE A QUEUE
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT
ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE IF YOU HAVE
NOT ALREADY. YEAH THAT'S ONE
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LOT NUMBER. LOCAL
FIRST ONLINE NUMBER THIRTEEN
ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN BURKE
BROUGH BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG OR. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER PLEASE THANK. THANK YOU
NEXT WE ALIGN FIFTEEN ONE FIVE.
MISTER MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
THIS POLYURETHANE OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT. MAKING A SPEAKER. WE
HAVE LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR.
YOUR CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
CHILLY AT NIGHT OR WITH THE
SAME BURKE INSTITUTE WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE A CO SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. AT
THIS TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
LINE TO QUEUE FOR SUPPORT R. I.
WE CAN OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- MEMBER JUST STATE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION OR WITH
AND- WHETHER YOU. AND YOUR
OPPOSITION TO IT. GOING OPEN
LINES PLEASE IF. THANK YOU FEEL
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHT ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
LINE TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THEN THAT MEANS WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
MISSPOKE SILVA- YES I WANT TO
JOIN WITH THE OTHER SHARON WHO.
IS A PART OF THE SUPPORT OF
THIS BUILDING- THIS BILL THE
SHARON'S I GUESS WE CAN CALL
OURSELVES THE HOUSING SHARON'S.
AND ALSO THANK THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR BRINGING
BACK- THIS BILL TO US AS IT'S
AN EXTREMELY MEANINGFUL ON JUST
GONNA READ FROM OUR- NOTES HERE
BUT IT'S STUDY AFTER STUDY
SHOWS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
DECREASES EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS HOSPITAL INPATIENT STAYS
STAYS NURSING HOME DAYS AND
PSYCHIATRY PSYCH PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT ADMISSIONS SAVING
BETWEEN. THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PER
BENEFICIARY ABOVE THE COST OF
HOUSING AND SERVICES. THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY MEANINGFUL AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I KNOW ON
OUR RECESS SOME OF THE HOUSING
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO BE REALLY
INVESTIGATING LOOKING AT DATA
AND TRYING TO DEFINE WHAT CAN
WE DO THAT WE'RE NOT DOING AND
WHAT ARE BEST PRACTICES. BUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS RIGHT NOW.
FULLERTON HOSTS A RECUPERATIVE
CENTER AND THIS ON NOT ONLY
ALLOWS PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BUT ALSO IF
SOMEBODY IS FACING A HEALTH
CRISIS AND WHEN THEY ARE
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL THEY
ARE THEN ABLE TO. AN EIGHT S.
AND STAYED THERE. TO RECUPERATE
AS WE KNOW IF THEY GO BACK TO
THE STREETS WE'RE TALKING MORE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS SO AS WE-
START TO FOCUS IN ON THESE
BILLIONS OF HOUSING DOLLARS. I
THINK ONE OF OUR GOALS HAS TO
BE HOW DO WE TRACK USE DATA TO
FIND OUT THE BEST WAYS TO NOT
ONLY SERVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
ALSO THE NEXT STEPS FOR THEM
AND RECUPERATIVE CARE CERTAINLY
IS PART OF THAT. SO I'M REALLY
PROUD TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU I THANK
YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS. IF NOT.
MR TO THANK YOU EVENT OUR
MOTION SECOND I WICKS IN A
SECOND BISOLA. MR TO READ LIKE
TO CLOSE THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WHEN COLORADO
PLEASE- WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BECOME
CARD IN CHU CHU I SEE ARE TO
KNOW THEY ARE NOPE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I'D KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN CORK SILVA
OKAY SILVA I WEEKS WEEKS I.
FIVE THANK YOU THE MEASURE
PASSES. THANKS VERY MUCH BACK
TO THE CHAIR THANK MISTER VICE
CHAIR. THAT CONCLUDES THE
PRESENT PATIENTS BUT I KNOW WE
HAVE TO GO BACK INTO THE VOTES
IN THE SENATE AS A
PRESENTATIONS. AND WITH THAT IF
I COULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
MOVE FOR FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BY GRAYSON
IT'S A MOTION BY WICKS SECOND
BY GABRIEL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- THIS WITH
THEIR ACCOMMODATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BEACON COURT IN
TRUTH HI CHIU I SEE OUR DON'T
BUY THE ART BY GABRIEL. GABRIEL
LIGHT KALRA. KALRA AYEKILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. QUICKSILVER CORK
SILVA I WEEKS. WEEKS OUT. YOU
HAVE SUPPORT SIX THANK YOU I
THINK WE'VE TAKEN MOTIONS AND
EVERYTHING LET ME JUST SAY THIS
BEING. VERY LIKELY LAST-
HOUSING COMMITTEE I JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON THIS-
INSURANCE COMMITTEE FOR SIX
YEARS AND- IT HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR. TO WORK WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU AND
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF HAD WHEN A
LOT OF ISSUES BUT WE OBVIOUSLY
NOW WE'VE GOT A LOT MORE WORK
TO DO. SO JUST APPRECIATE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU AND I ALSO
WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK MY- INCREDIBLE COMMITTEE
STAFF- WHO EACH OF YOU KNOW HAS
WORKED SO HARD AND SO WELL. ON
ALL THESE ISSUES SUGGEST-
APPRECIATE EACH OF THEM- LISA
ANGLE STEVERSON. CENTER NOT
GALA- DISPUTA. AND JUST THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
WITHOUT- WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ROLL AUTUMN OPEN FOR I THINK
ONE MORE MEMBER TO VOTE BUT AT
THIS. TIME OUR BUSINESS IS
CONCLUDED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT
WE ARE BACK AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE MEMBER TO ADD ON TO OUR
THREE ITEMS ON FILE ITEM ONE AB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN GRAYSON MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN. OKAY. DIMENSION
AND FILE ITEM THREE- SB THREE
ONE PORTANTINO MR MENTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WITHOUT WE ARE OFFICIALLY
CONCLUDED.